la poste en grève c'était notre fait du
jour on passe à présent la chronique
sport bonsoir Anthony bonsoir Wilfried
on va faire un point complet sur le
sport actualité chargé encore ce soir
oui tout à fait on va d'abord parler de
boxe et revenir sur ce superbe combat ce
week-end
sur ce plateau face au champion d'Europe
des super moyens James zigal avec son
entraîneur Antoine Farrugia bonsoir à
vous deux on parlera aussi de Raymond
Poulidor le plus célèbre second de
l'histoire du sport français nous avons
obtenu une interview exclusive il car il
sort un livre sur ses 50 premiers tours
de France et enfin nous vous ferons
découvrir le sport qui cartonne ces
derniers mois la zumba et nous
essaierons un peu d'expliquer les
raisons de ce succès et puis en fin de
chronique comme d'habitude les résultats
du week-end Antoine Farrugia je vous ai
vu être tout à fait d'accord sur cette
légende qui était Raymond et qui est
toujours
en revanche la zumba vous connaissez oui
oui
alors donc ce week-end a dit là vous
étiez sur le ring pour essayer de
d'obtenir cette superbe ceinture de
champion d'Europe des super moyens face
à James zigal malheureusement
défaites au point serrées mais des fêtes
au point commun quel état d'esprit
avez-vous aujourd'hui déçu un goût amer
oui parce que bon bah je m'attendais
quand même à revenir avec cette ceinture
pour moi c'était une ceinture qui était
à ma portée donc j'ai fait
tout ce que j'avais à faire pour pouvoir
obtenir cette ceinture vous avez suivi
d'ailleurs pendant votre préparation à
l'entraînement donc là apparemment les
la décision n'a pas été là on voit
justement les images de ce beau combat
vous avez été offensif au final quand
même vous avez plutôt avancé James vigal
est resté longtemps dans les cordes sans
être vraiment entreprenant et bah au
final c'est quoi c'est le fait qu'il
soit chez lui qui qui garde cette
ceinture je pense bien j'ai pu lire
différentes choses aussi sur la presse
anglaise et puis je pense que ça lui a
laissé quand même un certain avantage
d'avoir été chez lui
parce que si je pense aussi si on avait
été peut-être en France ça serait le
résultat n'aurait pas été le même les
images qu'on a vu il y a quelques
instants justement du combat c'est
difficile de revoir des images d'un
combat comme ça quand on est passé tout
près en plus là c'était pour le titre
alors là j'ai pas encore vu j'ai pas vu
le revenu le combat mais c'est vrai sur
le sur ce que j'ai pu voir
bon bah c'était ça faisait partie de la
stratégie qu'on avait pu mettre en place
avec Monsieur Farrugia et puis
de ne pas déçu de ne pas de ne pas être
rentré encore une fois avec cette
ceinture quoi Antoine Farrugia votre
poulain il n'a pas rougir quand même de
ce combat non il peut que quatre fiers
de ce combat moi j'en suis très fier et
je voulais vous dire pour replacer un
peu le contexte c'est-à-dire que ce
garçon notre adversaire était quand même
champion olympique il est champion
d'Europe en box amateur en 2008 voilà et
les champions d'Europe en professionnel
donc il est chez lui c'est une star
là-bas et franchement ils nous donnait
que quatre roues là on est arrivé que
pour faire quatre ondes alors soyez moi
la surprise a été énorme et et moi même
je suis très heureux parce que bon on
n'a pas la ceinture c'est vrai mais il a
gagné en notoriété croyez-moi surtout
que Adila ça fait que trois ans que vous
êtes professionnel donc le monde de la
boxe professionnelle et est encore un
peu
nouveau presque on va dire c'est plus ou
moins nouveau c'est vrai que là on
essaie de franchir les étapes
correctement avec Monsieur Farrugia on
se met des objectifs et le but c'est de
les atteindre et on les atteint
normalement avec
avec succès je dirais est-ce que vous
êtes déjà champion de France voilà
on visait les Europe on nous a laissé
l'opportunité de le faire il est arrivé
un peu trop tôt à mon avis il est arrivé
un peu trop tôt ce combat et à 6 mois 8
mois après c'était bon vous pensez qu'il
peut la décrocher cette ceinture
vous avez encore quelques années de box
devant vous c'est vous vous n'arrêtez
pas à cause de cette déception non
j'arrêterai pas à cause de cette
déception si on se met quand même mon
prochain objectif dans tous les cas ça
va être d'obtenir cette ceinture avant
je dirais l'année prochaine j'espère
2013 je me dis on va commencer à 2013 je
reviens avec avec la ceinture qu'est-ce
que vous allez changer est-ce que vous
allez changer des choses pour
l'entraînement oui oui on va changer
beaucoup de choses parce que vous savez
il faut chercher à s'améliorer donc on a
forcément du travail sur la planche déjà
je lui apprendra à changer de rythme un
peu plus souvent et puis taper avec plus
de avec un peu plus d'élan parce qu'il a
une telle frappe que s'il arrive à
mettre un peu plus d'élan peut-être que
ça va tomber plus facilement
et vous parliez tout à l'heure à Dylan
du fait que vous n'ayez pas vous n'étiez
pas à domicile on connaît un peu ces
difficultés de comptage des points lors
des combats de boxe il y a un scandale
qui secoue la box amateur en ce moment
c'est tout ce qui s'est passé aux JO de
Londres notamment pour le boxeur
français Alexis Vastine on se rend
compte qu'il y a un gros gros problème
derrière ce comptage on pourrait presque
parler de magouille au niveau de la
Fédération internationale de boxer
justement ce qu'on donne moi j'ai déjà
dénoncé pas les Jeux Olympiques parce
que c'est pas ma partie moi je suis
professionnel donc je m'occupe que de la
box pro mais j'ai déjà vu bon les
scandales avec Alexis et Vastine je suis
la deuxième fois c'est pas normal en
2000 en plus je suis en 2012 cette année
sport amateur quand ça arrive chez nous
on est les pros on peut expliquer qu'il
y a de la magouille parce que c'est une
question d'argent mais il s'agit jamais
changé mais enfin on a un président qui
est vice-président de la IBA il est pas
pu capable de faire autre chose moi
c'est ça que je reproche vous qui avez
connu justement le monde amateur comme
ça fait que trois ans que vous êtes Pro
vous avez vous avez déjà senti un peu
cette atmosphère autour des arbitres qui
c'est une certaine manipulation on
emploie le terme j'ai pu j'ai pu le
rencontrer sur certains sur certains
combats un amateur ensuite en pro on a
pu le voir dans tous les cas quand on a
pu se déplacer aussi très souvent
c'était ça entre autres lames et deux
derniers combats j'ai en juillet au
Monténégro où il y a eu une décision
pareil flagrante plus encore pire que
qu'en Angleterre
bon on a pu avoir le temps qui a été
réduit on a pu on n'a pas forcément
compris l'aider la décision on a pas eu
on n'a pas eu le droit d'avoir
le pointage enfin bon c'était
bon
être à combattre justement pour
décrocher ces différents titres
félicitations encore pour ce combat
malgré tout donc au championnat d'Europe
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur ce
plateau on vous recevra prochainement
pour voir comment ça progresse et voir
si vous réussissez enfin à décrocher
cette ceinture